how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we have something really big to talk
about today yesterday Disney had their
shareholder meeting and they showed New
Avengers in-game footage all the
shareholders got to see this new footage
and some of them have even leaked the
descriptions of what they saw online
right now it's unclear whether or not
this is a scene from the movie or if
this is actually the second official
trailer that we're supposed to get for
Avengers in game not too long from now
either way it's new footage that was
shown and we have the description so
I'll read it to you and then break it
all down quick reminder about my
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets so you
and some friends can go see Avengers
in-game all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
okay obviously have to issue some
spoiler alerts right now if you do not
want anything spoiled for Avengers in
game you should click away now okay so
this Avengers and game scene takes place
at the Avengers headquarters Captain
Marvel is there and she says let's go
kill Fanus nebula says that she knows
where Thanos is and rocket says the
biggest energy surge that Earth has ever
seen is when Thanos did the snap and
this surge was seen on another planet
shortly after so they say that's where
Thanos is retiring - there's a quick
exchange between Captain America Natasha
Bruce Rhodey and Captain Marvel Bruce
asked what kind of guarantee they have
that this ends differently this time and
Captain Marvel says you have me this
time Rhodey then questions Captain
Marvel asking where she has been this
whole entire time because they could
have used her before Captain Marvel says
there are a lot of other planets out
there that need help and they don't have
Avengers like the earth has Thor gets up
from sitting quietly in the back walks
up to Captain Marvel and summons
Stormbreaker it whizzes right past
Captain Marvel and she doesn't even
flinch it goes right into Thor's hand
and he says I like this one it then cuts
to the Milano everybody is buckled up
and Captain Marvel is in the copilot
seat rocket ass who hasn't been to space
and Captain America rody and Natasha
raised their hands in which rocket then
warns them not to puke in his ship
there's a reflection of stars and space
in Captain America's eyes and they zoom
in on him and they warp out of there so
that's it for the description I
basically read it
forward and there are a few things to
note here one is that Captain Marvel is
already here if you've seen Captain
Marvel this makes sense to you another
thing is that this most likely takes
place during the first 15 to 20 minutes
of the movie just like Kevin Feige said
in an interview and a big thing here is
that Tony Stark is not mentioned at all
clearly nebula is back but again no
mention of Tony Stark or Iron Man
whatsoever now he may not have been
there at this moment he may have left to
go see Pepper or he could just simply be
too hurt and be at a hospital right now
or of course he could have died I don't
want to speculate too much but again
he's not mentioned at all on this leaked
description and the last thing is that
this actually fits the bill for a second
trailer pretty well it doesn't really
give us too much information
about the movie but it does show Captain
Marvel and the Avengers going into space
and gives us a little bit more new
footage so it's enough new footage to
satisfy us with a second trailer but it
doesn't really give us any more new
information besides the fact that the
Avengers are going to try and find
Thanos to undo the snap which we all
pretty much knew we should be getting
the second trailer within a month so it
looks like we'll have to wait to find
out so that's it for the New Avengers
in-game description that we got from a
shareholder of Disney let me know what
you think about this description in the
comments down below do you think this is
footage from the movie or do you think
that it's going to be the second trailer
let me know and again don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame and Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching Wolf
Wolf
[Music]